Чи знаєте ви, наскільки небезпечний азбест?
Це токсичне волокно широко використовувалося у 70-80-х роках.
Багато будівель, таких як цю школу позаду мене,
більше не можна використовувати, оскільки, окрім інших проблем, вони повні азбесту.
Сам матеріал - високотоксичний.
Нині азбест є причиною половини усіх ракових захворювань.
Німець Вольфґанґ Ляйнер-Вейґандт захворів саме на такий вид раку.
У 1970-80-х роках він працював муляром, різав азбестові листи.
Він захворів на азбестоз - хворобу, спричинену впливом азбесту,
яка десятиліттями пізніше переросла в рак легень.
Коли чуєш діагноз – рак легень, ти просто шокований і навіть не питаєш чому.
Першу підказку ми отримали в лікарні.
Вони запитали, чи контактував я з продуктами, що містять азбест.
Ось тоді до мене дійшло: так!
Близько 70-ти країн світу заборонили чи обмежили використання азбесту,
включно з Німеччиною. В Україні використовувати азбест в будівництві заборонили лише у 2022 році
– під тиском ЄС.
Але в інших країнах світу, наприклад в Індії,
його продовжують використовувати попри летальні наслідки.
Якщо його не можна безпечно використовувати в цих 70 країнах,
тоді його не можна безпечно використовувати і тут, в Індії.
Але що таке азбест і наскільки він небезпечний?
Де люди найбільше піддаються впливу?
І як можна припинити його використання в майбутньому?
Азбест — це природний мінерал, який видобувають із шахт.
Його волокниста природа та стійкість до тепла, електрики і корозії
зробили його цінним для багатьох етапів будівництва,
таких як ізоляція стелі, підлоги та покрівлі.
Використання азбесту стрімко зросло після Другої світової війни,
особливо в Європі. А також в країнах Азії та Близького Сходу.
Зі збільшенням використання азбесту
зростала і кількість захворювань – аж до сьогодні.
Дослідження показують, що захворювання, пов’язані з азбестом,
спричиняють приблизно 255 тисяч смертей на рік у всьому світі.
Азбест викликає хронічне виснажливе захворювання.
Він викликає мезотеліому, азбестоз, рак легенів.
Небезпека азбесту полягає в тому, що в більшості випадків
він не викликає захворювання одразу.
Волокна можуть перебувати в легенях десятиліттями,
а хвороба може проявитися – на десятиліття пізніше.
Як і у випадку з Вольфґанґом.
Йому діагностували рак легень у 40 років
- через багато років після того, як він працював з азбестом.
Звичайно, спочатку цього не помічаєш.
Просто кашляєш. Є трохи мокротиння.
Тоді я ще палив. Але навіть тоді ти думаєш,
що кашляєш від того, що палиш.
Немає негативних думок і раку ти не помічаєш.
Зазвичай це стає помітним лише тоді, коли стає занадто пізно.
Багато інших людей страждають так само,
і часто це погано закінчується.
У Німеччині щороку від захворювань, пов’язаних з азбестом, помирає приблизно 1300 людей.
Ця цифра може бути більшою, оскільки багатьох хворих
не визнають хворими саме на азбестоз.
Отримати точні дані про те, скільки людей захворіло або померло на глобальному рівні,
ще складніше, адже багато країн не збирають цих даних.
Однак, за оцінками, 50 тисяч людей в Індії щороку знаходяться під загрозою смерті.
Ось чому так багато країн почали обмежувати або забороняти використання азбесту
з кінця сімдесятих років. Але є серйозні винятки.
ЄС заборонив азбест у 1990-х роках, і ми бачимо,
що з того часу його використання значно скоротилося.
Однак в країнах Азії та Близького Сходу його використання продовжується.
Згідно з даними ВООЗ, у всьому світі азбест все ще використовують у понад 30-ти країнах,
де недостатньо засобів контролю та неврегульоване законодавство.
Ці матеріали висуваються як швидка, дешева альтернатива, яку можна легко використовувати.
Але, знаєте, часто про довгострокові наслідки забувають.
Деякі країни все ще активно займаються виробництвом або використанням азбесту
попри всі ризики, які приносить цей канцероген.
Китай, Бразилія та Казахстан були одними з найбільших виробників азбесту,
разом видобуваючи близько 550 тисяч метричних тонн.
Проте країною, яка перевищила їх усіх у 2022 році, стала Росія.
РФ експортувала азбесту на суму понад 180 мільйонів доларів США.
Дуже прибутковий бізнес для країни.
Без Росії світова торгівля азбестом не процвітала б так,
як це відбувається сьогодні.
Там навіть є місто під назвою Азбест, де видобувають волокно.
Його також називають "містом, що вмирає"
через напрочуд високу кількість випадків захворювань на рак.
Деякі видобувні країни використовують азбест самостійно,
інші - експортують його по всьому світу.
Серед найбільших споживачів азбесту є Росія, Індонезія та Китай
із загальним обсягом понад 400 тисяч метричних тонн у 2021 році.
Але Індія перевершує будь-яку іншу країну за використанням азбесту.
Ви не можете уявити жодного місця, де б не було азбесту.
Він в будівлях, трубах водопостачання, транспортних засобах,
у їхніх гальмівних колодках і гальмівних накладках, у відсіках для баків.
Немає місця, де б не було азбесту.
Протягом останніх десятиліть Індія потроху закривала власні шахти,
але потім почала імпортувати матеріал у величезних кількостях.
Країна використовує азбест в основному в будівельному секторі,
майже не дотримуючись правил охорони здоров’я.
Біологія людини всюди однакова.
Якщо в Європі азбест отруйний, то і в нас він отруйний.
Якщо його не можна безпечно використовувати в цих 70-ти країнах,
то його не можна безпечно використовувати і тут, в Індії.
Це бомба уповільненої дії.
Дослідники побоюються, що протягом наступних кількох десятиліть
понад 6 мільйонів індійців захворіють на захворювання,
пов’язані з азбестом, у тому числі понад 600 тисяч – на рак.
І найгірше те, що багато індійців не усвідомлюють,
що вони можуть бути наступними.
Це моральний обов'язок усіх людей, які розуміють його небезпеку, діяти негайно.
ВООЗ наполягає на негайному припиненні використання азбесту.
Краще припинити використання зараз,
а потім давати раду з наслідками, успадкованими 50-60 років тому.
Але якщо країна продовжує використовувати азбест - це лише посилює проблему.
ООН робила кілька спроб заборонити азбест,
але їх блокували ряд країн, включно з Росією та Індією.
Але одна країна, яка була активно залучена в торгівлю азбестом,
тепер зробила поворот. Бразилія заборонила видобуток азбесту у 2022 році після того,
як Верховний суд уже припинив його використання всередині країни.
Чи може це стати поворотним моментом в історії азбесту?
Регіональні експерти не впевнені.
Ця повна заборона далека від реальності.
У липні 2023 року Бразильська асоціація людей,
які зазнали впливу від азбесту, заявила, що попри заборону,
азбест продовжують комерціалізувати та використовувати в Бразилії.
Це може мати наслідки на десятиліття вперед, як ми бачимо у Європі.
Тим часом у Німеччині, через 30 років після заборони, захворювання,
пов'язані з азбестом, продовжують зростати.
Вольфґанґу пощастило. Він поборов рак.
Сьогодні йому майже 70, але він ніколи не забуде день,
коли почув свій діагноз.
Того дня до мене випадково завітала донька.
І я повідомив їй сумну новину.
Я сказав: "Мелані, у мене є 50% шансів".
Це було брехнею, бо у мене було лише 10%, але я тримався за них.